es el final de semanas de incertidumbre
mario draghi fue designado primer
ministro luego de la reunión con el
presidente sergio mataré la foto efe
brayó el profesor mario draghi aceptó la
tarea de formar un nuevo gobierno y
presentó las propuestas al presidente
relativas al nombramiento de ministros
ministro el economista de 73 años
liderará un nuevo gobierno de unidad
nacional para reemplazar la coalición de
giuseppe conté que colapsó el mes pasado
reúne a tecnócratas y una variedad de
partidos políticos rivales desde los
liberales históricos hasta el movimiento
antisistema y la extrema derecha
luigi dimaggio líder del movimiento
cinco estrellas seguirá siendo ministro
de relaciones exteriores y giancarlo
giorgetti una figura destacada del
partido nacionalista liga se convertirá
en ministro de desarrollo económico sin
embargo algunos puestos claves fueron
para tecnócratas no afiliados entre
ellos daniel franco ex vicegobernador
del banco de italia quien encabezará el
ministerio de economía las figuras del
partido están de acuerdo
del lado sus diferencias al menos por
este momento mientras esperan decidir
cómo gastar a italia más de doscientos
mil millones de euros en fondos de
recuperación de la unión europea el país
se encuentra en su peor crisis económica
desde la segunda guerra mundial y sigue
luchando contra la pandemia de
coronavirus que ya se ha cobrado la vida
de más de 93 mil personas